hey everyone it's Mike Votto's from
water flows calm and this is the second
part of the Tuesday October 17th order
closed market analysis honestly I had
some second thoughts about doing this I
wasn't gonna do it because I got been
getting some nasty emails from people
nasty comments say no you know it's it's
uh you know there's no value in this but
you know I do know that for some people
they do get value out of it that's what
that's why I do it you know if you're
not interested in it just click on
something else you know your your your
comments are noted but you know I I do
know I do get emails for people that's
what keeps me going honestly is the
positive feedback you know I get five
negative comments but if I get that one
positive comment from somebody saying
hey you know what it really made a
difference in my trading then that's
that
means the world to me you know that's
why I do it so a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results again the tools we used in this
presentation are the order flows trader
the volume footprint chart the delta
scalper and the price rejecter so let's
take a look at some of these markets now
if you remember in the first
presentation I had talked about the euro
currency and that low that we had early
in the European session at I think 11792
and a half let me just get the chart up
here real quick okay so if I just show
you on the bar chart really quick if you
remember we had hit this low here we had
a few failed divergences on the way down
and I said you know if we take out this
low again watch out market could sell
off we did take out that low around for
about 450 for 15 here we made the low
buy a ticket then we rallied back up you
know if your breakout trader you know
those are the breakouts that suck but
again you know that that's not the in
the world you know you take your stop
you get your you take your loss with
your stop and you look for the breakout
again and you finally got it down here
at 11792 you know we hit 91 and a half
and just fell off all the way down down
into the low 70s down here
what was that 74 was the low so you know
it's I did feel this market did have a
capacity to go lower yesterday and and
it did here's the here's the chart of
when we broke the second time you know I
said we had that first break here by a
tick then we rallied then we came down
here here at 117 83 you have the price
rejecter you do have divergence at a
ratio market did rally up a little bit
here but mostly one sideways you can see
how you get these morning controls just
lining up here then you sold off went
down down down you got a new low down
here this low is interesting um you know
one 1774 he came back down within a tick
of it
you got a single print another single
print and then the market put in a nice
rally you do have a divergence you do
have some trapped traders down in here
that's what this green arrow indicates
and the market did I did put in a nice
rally there now the other markets I'll
talk about are the bonds in the five
years first we'll start in the bonds and
just get the bond chart here and again
is it's it's one of those classic trades
that I talk about all the time so you
know very tight range most the morning
you sell off nice this nice move down
guru new racial racial ratio all selling
imbalances on this move down you get
down here you got a divergence you got
the Delta scalper actually right on this
low rally up on the low all the way up
to the high again make a new high
actually but you know what else do you
have on this loan you had a divergence
you don't have a ratio excuse me so you
got your divergence your honor the ratio
but they look to the next part for the
divergence for the ratio sorry and you
got it so you got the Delta scalper you
got the divergence and you got the ratio
in the next bar again I say when you got
the divergence and the ratio on the next
bar it's still a legitimate trade
opportunity and you can see you know so
even if you're getting in on the second
bar here or sorry after the second bar
you're still catching a nice move you
know if you're getting in off the Delta
scope or off the low
you can't put the low up to the high you
know those are the trades that that you
want I mean you know it's not like
taking ten different trades a day you
only need to take one trade if it's if
it's a trade like this where rallies
from the load of the height you know
some people they like action you know
they want to have 10 trades I want to
have as many trades as possible for some
reason I don't know maybe they want to
put their brokers kid through school or
something I really don't understand that
said it's not about the quantity of
trades it's the quality of the trades so
here's the 5-year similar strong selling
coming out into the low you got ratio
ratio ratios selling imbalances sound
imbalances you hit this low the first
time you got a racial divergence you got
the price rejecter given a buy signal
market start school rally comes back
down test the low again boatload more
volume trades now now you got a thousand
here you ain't got 7,000 you get this
big selling imbalance here big buying
imbalance Delta scalper you know right
around the low Delta scalpers kicking in
it's not on the low the first time it's
not the second time you hit the low so
you know we were selling off selling off
selling off you know strong negative
deltas you start seeing some things
change in here and you know if you know
how to if you know how to read the Delta
you could pick it up if not you know you
you could see it in the Delta scalper
will signal it to you that it's changing
from atom a supply driven market to a
demand driven market and again you know
you have everything giving you buy
signals here you've got ratio and
divergence here price rejector here
Delta scalper here you know point of
control store at the bottom and you
rally you here Elliott from the O nine
area all the way you know you get up
here to the close at that is nine and a
half ten and a half so you know even
though it's a five years okay so you
know you don't get monster moves in the
fives you know you're lucky to get you
know I mean it's for you know from oh
nine to ten is one full tick that's four
ticks of the you know for ticks because
they trading quarter ticks but you know
from oh nine up to ten and a half that's
six ticks you know in five years of the
market that moves slowly you know it's
you don't get you know full basis-point
moves that often
lastly I'll talk about
it's crude oil I got a crude chart it's
it's rollover week in the crude okay so
keep that keep that in mind so you know
you might when it's rollover week it
might not you might not be getting as
many signals as you like because you
know people are more concentrated are
really a bit more concerned with you
know doing their roles but you know so
it's debatable if yesterday you should
be in the November still already trading
the December this is a December I think
today Wednesday you should definitely be
in the December but it was interesting
how you came down into this low here
okay well let's just go back step back a
little bit yeah what do you got you got
a lot of signals here actually you know
this is the Delta surge given this nice
little cell here went down about 10
cents Delta surge giving you a buy now
they're not much on there then you got
Delta scuppered giving you a sell here
down into new lows you shorted from you
know eighty all the way down into the
50s
then you had Delta scalper off the low
here right you have actually you got a
divergence and a ratio is a zero number
it's a zero ratio actually so it's still
already shows blue and you got the Delta
scalper giving you a buy you know this
yellow I don't if you could see that
that's actually the Balto's that's the
transition I don't really talk about it
that much because it doesn't really
happen that often and it's an indicator
for the inner circle members and so but
this low you know this was a nice buying
opportunity this low here and you can
see how it made its nice rally up you
know I mean again even if you're not
buying it off the sell you're buying it
in here around sixty six sixty you know
sixty five between 65 and 70 in here you
know it's still you know it's still
giving you a nice move you know it's you
know helped with the stack bind and
balance so again you know from 70 all
the way up to you know above 52 bucks
and you know going into the three
o'clock all the the tool clock closes in
here I like to trade crude until about
2:00 in the afternoon for me most
contracts
other than equities close that you know
cash sessions in these other contracts
really is till two o'clock but I'm not a
big fan of trading crude oil into three
o'clock time period even bonds and fives
I don't really concern myself at that
time but those are those were some nice
moves you know then why are we trading
right now in the mean session and
evening session or trade you know this
morning right now it's 2:00 in the
morning it's trading 5233 okay what else
oh yeah I don't forget you know I got
this webinar on Thursday the 19th with
investor inspiration if you haven't
signed up you should might find
something interesting in there is this
Dax
working on a new indicator it's in the
testing mode still right now but it
looks pretty good
again you know this is I'll show you
something really quick here
I could find the right chart bear with
me
oh buns buns is the one I want to talk
about where's my bun chart buns nice
contract nice signals this morning also
and this high here is beautiful hi
you've got racial and divergence even
got the racial in the next bar you know
compare that to the previous high here
where you just have a divergence you
sell this divergence at rallies back up
here you got the divergence and the
ratio you got the sellin imbalances you
got a lot of nice things in here and you
can see how this market sold off from
this high 160 you know here in this next
bar around the 72-73 area you know just
boom straight down straight down to this
area 160 to 50 where you got some
supportive buying coming in you've got
Delta scalper giving you a buy signal
here right off this so you're coming
down in here you're starting to make
this move back up again a supply driven
market turning into a demand driven
market and this market you know just
goes sideways for the most part after
that I mean sideways higher but mostly
sideways and right now we're in the
we're in the new session or in the
Wednesday session but again you know
here you got on this low it's the 130
right you know cash opens in the buns at
2:00 a.m. she cago time now you do have
a buy signal here then right all right
are on the cash open you got the cell
with the racial and I virgins this one
fails it comes right back up I thought
this bars I felt this bars kind of
bullish I should I bearish rather
bearish she did it it didn't happen but
again it's right around the two o'clock
opening the cash open so no one can you
know if you take it you know did just
came right back so we'll see how it's
going to shape up in the bun so you know
so thanks everyone for putting up with
my droning I know some people don't like
the sound of my voice but hey whatever
you know you make your own YouTube
channel if you don't like it so thanks
for watching this you learn more about
order flow let's go to my website order
flows or go to Delta scalper to learn
more about the Delta scalper and be sure
to sign up for my webinar on Thursday so
thanks everyone have a great day bye bye